danach ist es nicht viel besser geworden
also es ist so es ist eine
riesenenttäuschung für die union
insgesamt dass davon auch nicht
beschönigen auf der anderen seite ist es
so dass wir noch die möglichkeit haben
eine regierung zu bilden es gibt keine
klare mehrheit für einen
kanzlerkandidaten und insofern werden
wir jetzt in die gespräche hineingehen
und schauen dass wir es schaffen eine
stabile koalition der mitte zu bilden
also es ist so dass morgen unsere
bundestagsfraktion takt und wir sind da
in gesprächen aber ich würde gerne
fraktionsvorsitzender bleiben
danke schön
ja soweit also ralph brinkhaus der gerne
fraktionsvorsitzende bleiben würde ich
hatte eben die gelegenheit mit silvia
brea zu sprechen sie ist eine der fünf
stellvertreterinnen und stellvertreter
von armin laschet und sie hat in den
letzten wochen und monaten will ich
sagen an der presse von sich sehr
verdient gemacht sie war immer da stand
rede und antwort ganz im gegensatz zu
anderen silvia brea heute morgen im
interview mit mir
49 prozent direkt wahlkreis haben sie
mit diesem ergebnis gewonnen das beste
ergebnis der cdu in deutschland was
haben sie anders gemacht als die anderen
kandidaten
ich weiß noch nicht ob es das beste
ergebnis ist ich bin einfach dankbar
dass ich ein gutes ergebnis bekommen
habe aber auch bei mir sind durchaus
verluste dann insofern freue ich mich
sehr dass ich das direktmandat gewonnen
habe vor allen dingen das erste mal
verteidigt habe ja es geht nämlich bei
so einer war natürlich um parteiprogramm
und parteien aber auch um gesichter und
da fragen sich natürlich viele jetzt
nach diesem wahl desaster von gestern
hat man den falschen kandidaten
aufgestellt lag es an armin laschet
also für uns und für mich sind die
inhalte entscheidend und in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf der so viele
menschen interessiert hat wie lange
nicht war mir das tatsächlich persönlich
lange viel zu unpolitisch und die themen
haben lange zeit gar keine rolle
gespielt auf die es wirklich ankommt für
die zukunft unsere unseres landes und
insofern für mich geht es darum eine
zukunfts koalition zu bilden das dieses
land stabil in die zukunft geht und vor
allen dingen die herausforderungen der
zukunft an fast mit guten ideen aber
frau brier nach 16 jahren angela merkel
ist man jetzt eigentlich auf die fdp
angewiesen dass die bei der ampel nicht
klarkommen denn sonst kommt man ja gar
nicht mehr zum tragen und die weitere
frage ist ja erwarten sie heute hier im
präsidium oder im vorstand widerstand
gegen die person armin laschet wer mich
ein bisschen kennt der weiß dass sich
interne dinge intern besprechen und wir
werden einfach gleich eine
vorstandssitzung haben präsidium
vorneweg wir werden die ergebnisse
analysieren und vor allen dingen dann
auch den fahrplan festlegen wie es
weitergeht aber alles andere bleibt
intern nun muss man natürlich auch in
diesen tagen immer nach münchen gucken
die haben ja auch einen gewaltigen
anteil daran dass nachtreten von markus
söder war alles andere als dienlich aber
die haben vorher schon gesagt also auf
platz zwei das reicht eigentlich nicht
herr blume hat heute morgen ein
interview bei uns gegeben da war man
nicht so ganz schlau geworden wie die
csu sich positioniert befürchten sie aus
der richtung dass der druck erhöht wird
also wir sind in enger abstimmung auch
mit der csu insofern ziehen wir als
union an einem strang und für mich ist
wirklich entscheidend dass dieses land
eine zukunfts koalition bekommt ihn
wirklich die themen anfasst und die spd
ist natürlich gefordert auch eine
koalition auf die beine zu stellen und
wir sind aber doch die letzten die sagen
wir stehen nicht für gespräche bereit
und schauen nur auf uns als partei für
uns galt schon immer zuerst das land und
dann die partei und das ist auch diesmal
so und deswegen stehen wir für gespräche
bereit demokratie technisch ist das ja
durchaus ein problem was wir erleben
denn sowohl herr scholz wie eventuell
auch herr laschet müssen ja im grunde um
dem jeweils kleineren und anderen
partner ziemlich viel zugeständnisse
machen das ist ja so ein bisschen die
verdrehung dessen was die wähler gewollt
haben denn es gibt ja schon noch eine
stärken reihenfolge die festgelegt wurde
durch den wähler also unabhängig davon
ob und wann wer mit wem spricht kann es
nicht darum gehen zugeständnisse zu
machen sondern ideen für die zukunft zu
haben nicht mit einem minus zu beginnen
sondern mit einem plus wo wollen wir hin
in welche richtung wollen wir gemeinsam
marschieren und auf welches ziel können
wir uns verständigen
und ich glaube darum muss es gehen ein
letzter blick auf morgen weil sie auch
fraktionsmitglied sind es ist denn
sinnvoll wenn herr laschet heute sagt
ich lasse mich da morgen erstmal als
fraktionschef wählen das hat ja
tradition in der cdu also wir schauen
mal ganz entspannt morgen auch in die
fraktionssitzung und dann werden sie ja
auch erfahren in welche richtung ist
die niedersachsen geben sich heute hier
die klinke in der hand bei mir zum glück
während althusmann ist bei mir etwas man
was macht man jetzt mit diesem ergebnis
wir haben verloren punkt wir sind nicht
stärkste kraft im deutschen bundestag
geworden ein sehr schmerzhaftes ergebnis
sollten auch nichts beschönigen nichts
schön reden auch nicht letztendlich
versuchen zu klammern sondern sehr klar
die lage zu analysen analysieren es
stehen zwei optionen entweder eine ampel
koalition oder eine jamaika-koalition
eine große koalition halte ich für
ausgeschlossen aber man muss schon sagen
dass die spd die wahl gewonnen hat sie
haben zugelegt die union hat massiv
verloren also ist der regierungsauftrag
doch zunächst bei der spd mann ist auf
die mithilfe quasi der fdp und der
grünen angewiesen dass man eventuell
noch zum zuge kommen in der tat es hängt
am ende an fdp und den grünen wie sie
sich entscheiden werden das bleibt
sicherlich abzuwarten es wird gesprochen
werden über denkbare koalitionsoption
aber wir sollten realistisch sein unser
ergebnis war nicht 25 sondern unser
ergebnis lag deutlich über 30 was wir
angestrebt haben haben wir nicht
erreicht müssen wir rückschlüsse ziehen
inhaltlich personell satirische was
empfehlen sie wie soll die partei mit
armin laschet umgehen ist es üblich dass
sich so ein kandidat dann erstmal zum
fraktionschef wählen lässt morgen würden
sie das empfehlen sollten sich jetzt
nicht alle in die büsche schlagen wir
haben gemeinsam gekämpft wir haben
gemeinsam verloren wir haben in diesem
fall nicht das ergebnis erzielt
bundesvorsitzende ist der
kanzlerkandidat gewesen er wird selber
entscheiden welche rückschlüsse daraus
zieht wir werden das jetzt im präsidium
beraten hat er den auf die macht selber
zu entscheiden
armin laschet ist der bundesvorsitzende
und insofern hat er alle denkbaren
optionen und die cdu gut beraten die
fehler im wahlkampf nicht zu wiederholen
nämlich nicht geschlossen aufzutreten
das war sicherlich auch eine frage des
vertrauens der bürger in uns das haben
wir enttäuscht vielen dank dass man der
landesvorsitzende der niedersachsen war
bei uns und damit zurück zu michael
krons